a friendly reminder if you have children  well i guess  even if you don't when you're not using  your phone or your tablet make sure it's  locked example number one seven-year-old  leah grabowski  her grandparents gave her a 20 amazon  account a little gift card  fair enough when she got on their tablet  within 15 minutes  she racked up a 3 200  bill she bought smart watches lego sets  refrigerators  all by accident well clearly leah is a  very smart girl but did you  ever imagine she could take it this far  you have to start much sooner than seven  explaining to children that money  doesn't grow on the tree  it doesn't well her grandparents were  able to cancel a few of the shipments  but  not all of them the rest were returned  and they're still waiting for their  money back  leah has now lost her screen time  privileges  and uses her holiday money on a gift for  her second grade  class lesson